Sneo is the Jar Jar Binks of the
Daiverse. They thought that inserting
him into the story would breathe some
new life into the franchise, but he just
ended up annoying us. He's embarrassing.
So why is Sneo the poster boy for Dawa?
It's pretty simple, really. For 13
centuries, Islam spread by force. In the
early 20th century, the Ottoman Empire
fought in World War I and lost. After
that, the caiphate fell apart. It was
clear that Islam could no longer compete
with far more powerful Western nations.
So, Muslims started focusing on da'wah
to spread Islam. But they realized that
most people knew next to nothing about
Islam. So, they lied about Islam a lot.
They made up all kinds of nonsense about
the perfect preservation of the Quran
and scientific miracles. And this worked
well because there was an atmosphere of
ignorance about Islam. People didn't
know anything about the Quran. So the
Dawagandists could say absolutely
anything. They kept going until the
internet and the availability of Muslim
sources made it easier to refute the
lies that were being told. The arguments
don't work on anyone who's familiar with
the topic. Or as we like to put it, the
arguments don't work on anyone who's
familiar with the DA script. This means
that daagandists who want to continue
using the arguments need to find people
who are still in a state of total
ignorance. And that's why the focus in
recent years has shifted to getting
popular influencers like Andrew Tate and
Sneo and now Lily Jay to spread Islam.
Muslim leaders know that people like
Andrew Tate and Sneo and Lily Jay have
some of the most ignorant and gullible
followers on the planet. And Muslim
leaders know they can get access to
these ignorant and gullible followers
through the
influencers. The goal is to win the race
that's going on. They need to dupe
enough people into converting to keep
Islam from falling apart just long
enough for Islam to take over some
modern countries and impose blasphemy
laws that will silence critics. Once the
critics have been silenced, no one can
object to the lies and Islam wins. So
that's why they're using Sneo. They want
access to his followers and they want to
steer his followers towards the shakes
who are plotting to subjugate the world.
A perfect example here is Shik Assam
al-Hakim who advises Muslims to prepare
for a time when they'll be able to go
doortodoor forcing people to either
convert to Islam, pay protection money,
or be executed. Jihad linguistically is
to struggle and technically it is to
fight for the cause of Allah. And what
is the reason behind such jihad? Number
one, to call them to Islam. It is for
da. The jihad is only for da'wah. That
is why when Muslims go and conquer the
the adjacent country, what do we do? We
kill them all? No. The prophet says the
first thing you do is call them to
Islam. If they accept it, leave them.
Tell us. They're Muslims. We go. If they
refuse then tell them Allah obliged upon
you to pay
taxation. If they refuse then we have to
fight and if we fight you then we
capture you. You become our slaves and
we take your land and you take because
you refuse. I give you two good options.
Sneo met with Shake Assam and he quickly
learned that he's not allowed to
question anything Muhammad said. Here's
Sneo's big question for the shake. I
I've been I was struggling with this one
ever since I read this hadith which um
stuff I have to admit I I didn't like
when I read it. And the hadith is uh the
prophet peace be upon him he said that
the people of Yemen are the best of
people. There are hadiths about what
Muhammad did to a little girl named
Aisha. Hadiths about beating women into
submission, even beating women until
their skin turns green. hadiths about
fighting and subjugating unbelievers
simply for being unbelievers and so on
and so on and so on. But the hadith that
really bothered Sneo due to his
perfectly functioning moral compass was
a hadith about the people of Yemen being
the best of people. First of all, we as
Muslims have to have
submission,
certinity, no questions asked, no
strings attached. This is Quran. I
believe it. Do you fully embrace it?
Yes. No questions asked. If Muhammad
said it, no questions asked, no strings
attached. You submit. And Shik Assam is
correct. according to the Quran surah
4:65. But know by your Lord, they can
have no faith until they make you, oh
Muhammad, blah blah blah, judge in all
disputes between them and find in
themselves no resistance against your
decisions and accept them with full
submission.
Islam means submission, but submission
to Allah requires full submission to all
of Muhammad's decisions. If you have any
resistance against any of Muhammad's
decisions, you have no real faith and
you're not a Muslim. You have to
unquestioningly obey everything Muhammad
says. And who received this
revelation?
Muhammad. This is a hadith. Do you take
it? Uh, is it authentic? Is it? That's
what I I read. Yeah. Then if it's
authentic, it's from Allah. How could I
be shaky? Because if you want to be
shaky, this means that you don't have
certinity. And when you don't have
certinity, you're this close to flipping
to the dark side. You don't question it.
Because if you question it, you don't
have certinity and you're in danger of
leaving Islam.
But I mean, how how are we able to judge
how authentic Hadith is? Or you don't
how do you judge whether this
neurosurgeon who's going to do a spine
cord surgery on you is authentic or not?
I judge by opinions of other people.
Okay. By whose people? Professionals.
Professionals. So you go to the
scholars. That's why I'm asking you. Go
to the
scholars. Which scholars? Muslim
scholars. Don't go to non-Muslim
scholars to find out if a hadith is
accurate. Because non-Muslim scholars
are going to give you a very different
answer. And I'm not talking about
Islamophobic non-Muslim scholars. I'm
talking about non-Muslim scholars who
defend Islam. What do they think about
the reliability of hadiths? Let me quote
a passage from Dr. Joshua Little, who's
made it one of his life's goals to
defend Islam against critics. He's a
non-Muslim scholar of hadiths. Here's
what he thinks about them. That hadith
are
unreliable. That any given matten,
that's the content of the story, cannot
be taken at face value as an accurate
datim from the first Islamic century.
and that any given isnad, that's the
list of people who transmitted the
story, cannot be taken at face value as
an accurate record of a Matten's
providence, cannot be seriously
contested for multiple reasons. Firstly,
there is an overwhelming prior
probability based upon the ubiquity of
fabrication and pseudepigraphy in late
antique and medieval
religiohistorical, pagan, Jewish, and
Christian ascriptions. He's saying that
lots of people were fabricating stories
during this time. Secondly, there is the
high frequency of contradictions within
the hadith corpus which necessitates the
occurrence of a huge amount of
fabrication, interpolation andor
mutation and therefore skepticism
towards any given hadith. Thirdly, there
is the ubiquity of fabrication and
interpolation, both reported and
demonstrable, in the hadith corpus,
which again casts doubt upon the rest of
the corpus. Fourthly, there is the rapid
extreme mutation and growth of reports
that evidently took place over the
course of a century or more of oral
transmission, which means that any given
matten regardless of the isnad is likely
at best heavily distorted and at worst
obliterated beyond its original form.
Fifthly, there is the belated emergence
of hadith as a genre and corpus largely
during the 8th and 9th centuries CE,
which straightforwardly precludes the
authenticity of most ascriptions to the
7th century
CE. In other words, non-Muslim hadith
scholars think the entire system is a
joke. That's why Sneo should only go to
a Muslim scholar who will lie and tell
him that they have certinity about these
stories. The biggest problem we have
with the Westerners from America and
from Canada and from Europe is that they
don't have their Islam on cemented area.
They're so easy to flip to the other
side. And that's why you find many of
them starting to be good and strong and
mashallah and all of a sudden I have
doubts. So people convert to Islam in
the west and they start off strong then
they have doubts. Why? I'll tell you
why. Dagandists lie to them to get them
to convert and then after they convert
they learn more about Islam and it's not
what they were told.
You told me Muhammad was the greatest
man who ever lived. Now that I'm reading
about him, he doesn't sound like the
greatest man who ever
lived. Why didn't you tell me about this
before I
converted? How does Shik Assam al-Hakim
respond when a Muslim has doubts?
I have doubts. Why? Uh, the prophet
married Aisha when she was nine.
Uh, you're a cafe.
If you doubt the prophet himself for a
second, you're a full-fledged caffer.
Get the heck out of my house. If you
doubt, you're a caffer. But you're a
caffer after you converted to Islam,
which makes you an apostate. That's a
dangerous thing to be in a Muslim
country, which is why it's far less
common to express doubts in a Muslim
country. So the local daagandis tells
you that Islam must be true because
Muhammad's character was so amazing and
because the Quran has been perfectly
preserved and because the Quran is
filled with miraculous scientific
insights and you convert before
bothering to do the slightest bit of
research. Then eventually you do some
reading, you watch some videos, you hear
some responses, and you realize that
everything the Daagandis told you was
complete nonsense. You express your
doubts to your local shake. And he says,
"Get out of my house. You're a
caffer." If you're in a Muslim
country, you're in
trouble. If you're in a Western nation,
you'll probably be okay for now. The
long-term goal of Shik Assam
al-Halhakeim and the Daagandists is to
make it unsafe everywhere to be a kafir
or an apostate so that no one will ever
be able to question Islam or express
doubts about it. Do you want to live in
a world where you have to mindlessly
agree with the ramblings of an
illiterate 7th century Arabian caravan
robber? If you don't, I suggest you
recognize that you're in this race, too,
whether you want to be or not.
And this is a race you'd better win.
[Music]